ooh what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about
optimizing health through precision
medicine we have Doug Jamison joining us
on the show hello hello how are you
doing today pleasure to be here on no my
pleasure thank you I did shout out to
Steve for introducing us to have a
really pretty friend intro yeah this is
how we remember who makes those intros
are talking about earlier we shout them
up at the beginning of the show
Doug's background Doug is the CEO and
founder of hail dot life you can check
out the link in the bio they're
currently reimagining primary care
medicine and this is gonna be a lot of
fun to talk about I'm super excited we
have a bunch of good visuals to show you
guys and unpack what the future looks
like here I'm excited let's start with a
big history take on civilization that we
like to start that way so we find
ourselves now stewards of Earth after a
long period of evolution we're kind of
getting into the exponential technology
age all this data now as we're gonna
talk about so what's your current take
on humanity I mean I'm a little worried
to say the least I think that a lot of a
lot of great minds have talked about
being on the the the back half of the
chessboard where technology is really
expanding rapidly and I spend a lot of
time thinking about you know the human
ability to adapt to all that change and
I think that we're probably you know
technology is moving faster than our
ability to adapt and I think you see
that in a lot of world events currently
and so one has to do a lot of thinking
as far as what happens when you're on on
that back side of the chessboard and
again I mean we talk about synthesizing
history what does that mean for you know
you and your career and your job and
what you need to do what training you'll
need for the future
what does it mean for raising kids in
this period of time as well so yeah I'm
glad that you took us there because we
frequent this conversation on the show
of we now have a billion of us on this
rock and we have all these exponential
technologies that are now entering into
our daily lives and what are we how do
we handle this how do we how do we do a
collective conversation about how to
best deal with the next steps for
Humanity so what do you think I'm like
how do how do we balance that we are one
mentality with the geopolitical
leadership thing don't know I mean I
probably the best the best description
I've heard and that I tend to agree with
is that you actually you have you have
sort of two evolutions going on right
you have this biological evolution we're
all we all have to you know we're all
subject to biological evolution happens
at a very very slow pace right yet I
mean I think they caught they caused
call it the cognitive revolution whereby
humans unlike any other species learn to
tell stories right and that that's what
we do that's what we do every day
running a company is about crafting
creating and telling a story life is
about telling a story we've talked about
you've all her re right which is you
know he would actually say money is a
story right empires are and
civilizations are stories religion is a
story
so we cramp these stories all the time
and that ability skyrockets it moves a
lot faster and and yet we sort of have
to balance these two conflicting ideas
of you know our biological evolution the
fact that we were tribal right with our
sort of psychological evolution which
has allowed us to create these
incredible you know empires that that we
do in these communities communities much
larger than evolutionary we ever did as
we lived in you know hunter-gatherer
tribes and things like that so I think
you know I constantly try to synthesize
you know how to balance those those two
effects and I think I think as humans
you know we struggle
that right the stories work so well
until they don't and then you know we
have a major sort of step back and then
they you know then someone crafts a new
story and they come up and I think that
I think what we need to do is just first
realize that we have to balance the
biology with I guess I call it the sort
of psychology right or there or the
cognitive revolution and understand that
balance far better if we're gonna be
able to again live in the age of
accelerating technologies yes yes yeah
because the biology is surely moving at
much slower rates than the exponential
technologies that are now in our pockets
and so yeah we're seeing a big a big
shift in many ways of doing things like
keeping the phone off for extended
periods of time doing things like going
on long periods of retreats or really
just exploring other ways of getting
back to this empathy looking at each
other and yeah yes expressing love and
care and compassion even though
someone's opinions may be different than
yours
I mean consciousness is is a wonderful
human trait right and so how do you you
know how do you develop consciousness
right we don't talk about computers and
intelligence but intelligence and
consciousness are two different things
right joy compassion empathy are very
much consciousness you know super
intelligence is the ability to solve
problems you know extremely difficult
problems or problems rapidly so yes it's
a it's it's an interesting world how do
you find you know how do you find
balance in that you know it there's an
upside I said the beginning I'm worried
but the other thing is is the beauty of
humans as those stories so right if we
can if we can craft the right type of
stories right that perhaps they're
balanced sort of what's gonna happen
biologically I I think we're in a good
place the question is is you know who's
got control of those those storylines I
read I've read a great book one's
probably the most influential book I've
ever read is called the origins of
wealth and I believe that Steve we
mentioned the beginning is the person
that put me on to it it it basically
looks at oh it looks at the world as a
complex adaptive system it's
written the first third of it is all
about the downside of economic theory
how wrong they got it then the back half
of it is all about how simple patterning
mathematical tiling patterns basically
create these elaborate worlds but in it
there's this great statement about you
know it talks about game theory right
and we know the outcomes a game theory
now right collaborate is the best
outcome than that you can areum yeah is
cooperate cooperate yeah
yet they played these things out in
computer algorithms now and you know why
don't we all collaborate collaborate and
there's a certain mean I'll define it
this way there's a certain percentage of
the population just natural population
that is you know in in that book it was
terms a sociopath afraid some some on
the spectrum of sociopath II some way
right and I heard it defined by a
gentleman Leo Wilson great naturalist
from Harvard as there's there's always
this battle going on between sort of you
know evolution at the individual level
selfish The Selfish Gene and things like
that and evolution thing at the group
level of course he was a great
entomologist studied ants throughout his
career and that that the the social miss
of ants and how they get things done and
clearly same concept we do better if we
cooperate in groups however you're
better off within the group if you're
the selfish one right so my guess is
biologically mathematically there's sort
of this equilibrium of what percentage
of us can operate um selfishly and still
have the group work right and again
societies and history we've gotten so
far as humans by cooperating but there's
an element that is you know that is sort
of the selfish element underneath that
and so in game theory what ends up
happening oftentimes is cooperate
cooperate best outcome next best outcome
if you're cooperating other parties not
cooperating is what punished harshly so
when Putin invades when Putin invades
Ukraine NATO should just light up at the
border and say take one more step and
we're blowing you to oblivion
that is the next best outcome the far
worse outcome is to appease the person
that's not collaborate and I always just
think of life is this constant battle I
mean you hear it talking about it but
this constant battle between like the
selfish and and the group of you know of
playing that out whether it's game
theory whether it's sort of you know the
the social good whether it's cooperation
and storytelling versus being selfish
and you know you just sort of wish that
we couldn't be Kaido no get rid of that
part of society and get to cooperate and
cooperate yes and and we'd have a far
better outcome for the world it feels
like the more that our ethics evolve the
further they evolve the further we get
closer towards the ability to all
harmoniously collaborate and all three
have our own individual interests at the
same time just mesh with that
collaborative spirit simultaneously that
we both realize that the individuals
prospering that the individual is
actualizing meanwhile the collective is
doing it at the same time alright let's
let's do the journey let's do the
journey on how on how does a misen got
to where he is today now optimizing
health and human performance let's talk
about this okay so I'll step back away
cuz doc Jamison started as a very
focused individual and then somehow got
got lost in what he wanted to do and
then sort of found himself again so I
guess it's the classic coming-of-age
story right so I I grew up I basically
went to college to dive like swimming
and diving springboard and tower diving
that's what I did where was it that I
went to Dartmouth College Dartmouth um I
trained that this is from this is the
big tall yeah towers so ours yeah we're
talking like you're diving 30 feet yeah
30 feet exactly correct yes so we Cal
what a good way to shatter your your
uncomfortability yeah yeah leap off one
of those towers and start spinning and
hope doesn't always happen but yeah so I
was a springboard diver in a tower diver
I went to colleges I trained with the
national team out of University of Texas
at every opportunity away from from
Dartmouth so competed at a very high
level
went to school you know I sort of
somewhere in high school they taught me
economic motivations para mountain man
and I I think at my young age I truly
believed it and so I was going into
economics and and going that classic
route and the beauty of a liberal arts
education is you find out there's a lot
more to it so I did I did a lot of math
and physics early on I found Asian
Studies
I wrote my senior thesis on agricultural
Reformation in preach Han China which is
200 BC and the unification of China so
very different than when I came in dough
dope through college trained seriously
but I left college and I didn't want to
go the traditional routes so I literally
wrangled on a ranch in Evergreen
Colorado for a summer with a buddy
beautiful I'd ridden horses so we did
that I did if you know Boulder County at
all I actually did the the first
economic analyses of whether it made
more sense to outright purchase the land
or do conservation easements so this is
in the early 90s when those
conversations were going on big and
boulder which purchased all the land
around Boulder to protect it
and so I did put my college degree my
economics to work for a short period of
time and then all my all my friends that
that seemed you know incredible they you
know they whitewater raft they climb
mountains they they scaled rocks at
Yosemite I grew up in the suburbs of
Philadelphia so I fled west and I I
decided to do graduate work and and
coached the University of Utah diving
team so I kept going with one thing I
didn't know how to do which was dive and
coach and train that so I coached there
and did graduate work and I did you know
they paid for all my education so I
ended up doing I had a physics major and
then I had economics and Asian Studies I
went on and did a geology undergraduate
I did biochemistry undergraduate and I
did my graduate work in economics and
mathematical statistics and I spent that
time there so just fast forward and up
in technology transfer but I still ran
this elite program coaching springboard
diving in Utah and ended up coaching
you're doing a lot across the state Rand
the state programs run younger programs
but I ran an elite program as well
where
divers came through and became junior
national finalists national finalist we
sent two athletes to the Athens Olympics
from the program so coaching it that
that higher level which will come back
when we talk about the circle through
not not linearly but and do that but so
I ended up in tech transfer which is
commercializing university technologies
you work with professors you take their
technologies you you basically work with
patent attorneys to patent that and then
you're looking for licensing I did that
at the University of Utah it was a great
place to do technology transfer very
entrepreneurial University and tech
transfer office and after doing that for
about five or six years I didn't have a
PhD and I lived my life with a whole
bunch of PhDs and I figure the only way
I was gonna get ahead was to find an
area that one PhD wouldn't cut it and
there was the rise of nanotechnology so
looking at matter below the micrometer
level at the nano scale and I got
heavily involved that's the portfolio
I've managed at University of Utah did a
lot of figured you know one PhD in
material science wasn't gonna cut it for
all the life science applications
electronics and engineering applications
and did that and lo and behold through a
friend it's always through mentors and
and friends and people you work with I
got introduced to a venture capital firm
in New York City Harris and Harris group
who had just changed their entire
investing focus to investing only in
companies enabled at the nano scale and
the concept was we could diversify the
industries we invested in because
there's you know nano scales for biology
for electronics and engineering as well
as energy yet we could have a focus
because you really needed a focus to
hire great talent and I joined there in
2001 and went on from I don't think they
wanted to hire me they were looking for
you know PhD MBA and and they got me but
I was the guy early on that believed in
the ability of it and I ended up being I
ended up being chairman and CEO of it in
2009 and ran it through 2017 when I
restructured it and
founded Heil whoa 16 years so 16 years
Harrison Harrison Harrisburg yeah long
venture all nanotech across different
fields so you evolved you evolved as a
business right so we did we did a lot of
nanotechnology and that we always did
nanotechnology through 2017 we went from
a generalist firm to doing only life
sciences in the last three or four years
and we even in the life sciences with a
lot that was changing in the capital
markets especially the micro cap public
market for which I wrote a book on
venture investing in science sort of
documenting all of those changes that
was published by Columbia University
Press we ended up moving away from the
drug deals to precision medicine really
which is you know the tools and
everything and there were there were
good reasons for it there was you know
the markets were changing drastically so
micro-cap markets which really drove
venture capital from the 1970s onward
remember Harrison Harrisburg the firm I
joined was around started in 1983 so Moe
I mean a longer time frame of a venture
firm than almost all the firms that
exist today and we were also a public
company we were publicly traded so we
had permanent capital during that period
of time so you weren't raising a fund it
wasn't an LP GP structure makes you
think a lot being a public company of
what to do but basically the public the
markets had changed the micro cap market
had been decimated there were no market
makers the idea of taking a company
public at two hundred three hundred
million dollars and letting it grow in
the public sphere disappeared now
they're all billion-dollar companies and
if you're a 200 to 300 million dollar
market cap company it's rough and yet
for venture capital 300 to 400 million
dollar funds which is effectively what
Harrison Harrah's Group became they went
from being 60% of all the venture
capital companies in America to less
than 15% I think it's down from there so
either he became very small doing you
know doing internet type deals or you
became very very large billion-dollar
funds so that you could write the checks
you needed to stay private longer and
Harrison harris couldn't do that she's
one of the reasons I reached
sure that doing it but so we we evolved
in a marketplace where you're public
because you're not it's not about your
last deal right I mean Harrison Erica
was in a great position we were you know
we had enough money coming in through
sales and IPOs each year to fund our
operations to make new investments you
know and and to make follow on
investments but when you're a public
company you start thinking about
compounding your growth rate and growing
assets and growing them in comparative
comparison to other companies in the
marketplace and that became really
difficult to do so the moment you have a
great exit you know you turn five
million dollars into 40 million your
shareholders don't go great I'm giving
you three years off make some other
investments I hope things go well they
go what are you gonna do for me today
and that's that's a much tougher world
so I think a lot of time we are we don't
necessarily look behind the veil of what
of some of the things that happen in in
investing and so when we see companies
that are impacting us on a daily basis
and the things that we do and the
services that we have provided to us
sometimes it's actually always I think
really important to look behind the veil
and see exactly how these companies
became how they did in and many times it
is these really important investments
that came through from from from people
that believed in the founding Tina
believed in the science and believed in
what they were doing so and it also
makes sense now with your deep science
background as well as the the diving as
well with the sports this kind of gets
us to you know hail life and Hill sports
as well so let's venture into what
happened yeah in 2017 so teach us about
like kind of like that aha moment and
then what happened with Hale like yes
it's Debra an aha moment it's probably a
series of moments and you know and sort
of I think it's best described sort of
in aspirations where you're thinking
about well what do I want to do and what
do we need to become and you know being
chairman and CEO of a public company you
spend a lot of time strategically
thinking you know about your business
about what you do do you do it well
everything and so we
if you step back to really 2007 you know
one of the the things that drove me and
and I think us as a firm at Harris and
Harris group was you had the the rise of
genomics and we were involved in that in
the in the 90s as venture capital and
everything but we started looking and
saying okay that's big now it's being
played out in the public sphere Illumina
is a public company big dollars going in
but what's the other information we need
beside it so you have you know genotypic
information but what is it's often
called phenotypic information but what
is the environmental side of the
nature-nurture equation right and and
what if we not only had your genomic
blueprint but we knew things like
proteomics epigenomics microbiome we
knew what was happening you're sort of
360-degree view could we actually
understand what was held happening
biologically or health or medically and
and we started looking at that and say
well look if you look at the rise of
genomics all these other technologies
are probably gonna lag but they're gonna
come right beside it and even if they're
smaller there's still a wonderful growth
opportunity be investing in those
companies and so we started investing in
the precision medicine space the
epigenetic companies the microbiome
companies the metabolomic companies all
of the other omics out there and so fast
forward a Ceti years and having looked
at those you know I started to say wow
these technologies are finally ready for
primetime we've watched these companies
grow up the company the technologies are
ready for primetime but they're either
being used in research at universities
who are buying these these services
these technologies or like the stage for
cancer right so if you look at cancer
research now it's incredible right you
look at immuno immuno oncology right
using your own immune system to fight it
and they found out that not only do you
know cancer tumors mutate so you want to
look at the sequencing of the genes
constantly but you also found out that
actually your microbiome the microbes in
your gut impact how well you'll respond
to those diseases and so you know you
see this coming together but it's like
stage 4 cancer when you get a team and
do that and I started asking the
question of why can't we use the same
technology ready for primetime and start
asking questions like if my health is
here now what trajectory am i on for the
next 10 years or 20 years and again I
got older in that period of time I'm 49
so you start to ask the question in 20
years when my kids are graduating from
college
am I gonna be healthy am I gonna be like
my own personal uncle who's 72 and bikes
70 miles on the weekend with my wife and
I am I gonna be like my father who has a
flip-flop foot has trouble walking needs
a stick and everything like that and
those are two different life
trajectories and so you start saying how
can we use this information to give us
these sort of prescriptive proactive
health care and that finally after sort
of working through that trying to
convince companies that they should go
more consumer route and medicine finally
was like look we can do this let's just
take this and go to the consumer let's
start Hale life and see if we can take
these technologies and use them to
reimagine primary care to to help people
optimize their health and athletes
optimize their performance
it was so crucial that you came in that
2007 ish time when you were watching the
initial follow-up omics developed not
the genomics but the proteomics and the
epigenomics and all these other omics
that are microbiome all of these
different developing technologies that
were that that are now able to give us
this blueprint of our environment as
well as well as the the nature the
nurture and the nature together which is
super interesting that that it's it is
now finally at the time where where
you're able to make these relevant
insights into people's lives that can
there's like you said there's a
bifurcation with your life potentially
where you can end up like a a super
healthy biking when you're 70 Pollak you
feel powerful when you're waking up and
stuff versus when you're feeling not
great at 50 even and so this is all
extremely valuable because the health
that we have it's the creativity that we
have it's the livelihood that we have as
we move forward and he's a pull in in
our lives so alright so now you know
you're finding your
self-making this basically this engine
so teach us about like we have when we
have some way of some good visuals to to
pull up as well that will help us kind
of walk through this but you know teach
us about this engine and kind of like
you know you you you let's start here
let's do it so so this is so again I
mean you saw just just sort of my
history is this developed and any um
price someone far smarter than I would
have would have put all this together a
lot faster than I did I mean it it built
for a period of time but basically you
know we're entering the age of consumer
medicine you know people know that
investors know that everybody's trying
to play that in one way or another
so that was one of the ideas the other
idea goes all the way back to college so
I got lucky at Dartmouth and I did a lot
of system dynamics work with early
system dynamics work done out at MIT and
done out of Dartmouth they started
looking at you know system level right
and probably one of the best things
about not being a PhD scientist myself
is I'm not stuck in you know what what
do you do when you do a PhD you you
basically become what scientists become
which of reductionists right you pick an
area and you understand it five six
seven eight layers deep and that's what
we've done in science has been a
wonderful I mean that the Scientific
Revolution is about reducing things and
understanding them but once you reduce
them all down
we're systems as humans right we don't
yeah you don't operate all individually
right don't hit one in serial manners we
operate as a system right and I think
that nanotechnology was the beginning of
looking at how at the nano scale
biologically inert molecules become not
inert right things happen at that cross
discipline so I live that in
nanotechnology I believed it from my
college days designing stocks and flows
and watching him for me you want to
watch the information flows right you
know the stock doesn't tell you anything
follow up follow the money flows not the
stocks following the flows tell you
where things are gonna happen and so my
my view of of the human sort of biology
has always been system levels so that's
not medicine medicine is reactive its
symptom based I have a symptom I have to
solve it you have a well-defined disease
state is a very reductionist right but
we're not
or complex holistic you know systems and
and and we're adaptive and sometimes we
get ourselves in these weird states
right and how do we get out of that and
I think that what Hale is doing and what
a lot of even medicine is starting to in
biology is building up from the
reductionist back to the system level
and trying to understand that and really
that's at the heart of Hale so what do
we do at Hale we basically look at a lot
of comprehensive information but the
idea that not only your blueprint your
genes right let's let's show that yeah
so we can actually get yeah go will go
to the next one and so here's kind of
yeah so basically you have all this
information available to you precision
medicine data that's all you're omec
information but nowadays you have
performance study of all these wearables
you collect information from you've
traditional medical data for the
athletes we'll talk about it we have
performance data we put them on force
plates and kamesha things and again the
world doesn't need more data right that
the the world needs to make sense of to
make sense of the data that's where
value lies making sense of the data and
so what we build is an engine and we
build an engine that ingests all this
different type of information it
collects it it organizes it normalizes
it it curates it in the language and and
then what we look to do is interrogate
it and integrate it so the idea is yeah
your genes give you a blueprint but
what's happening in your environment
that's gonna impact turning on and off
those genes right what's happening you
know with microbes in your gut there's
more cells of microbes in your body than
human cells right you're more microbe
than you are human right so what's
happening there that impacts things and
you know the the gut microbes and impact
what's happening not just in the immune
system and inflammation they impact you
know all the thought processes as well
you know that that gut to brain
connection is very very close from our
evolutionary days when we were worms and
so you know we look at all that gather
and the idea is to integrate it to be
able to tell you in a more holistic
360-degree way what is happening and the
idea is if we can do that you can then
start to think about what do I need to
do to optimize health and I'll give you
a classic example again you know you
start thinking how dumb you are
sometimes which is every
I went to the I've worked 17 years at
Harrison SR we had a great medical plan
right we had anything you wanted so I
went and get a physical every year right
do you know in like 16 years of
physicals never once did they put up the
year data for the year priors data next
to this years I never saw a lie oh I
never saw longitudinal inform oh shoot I
was lucky if they even called me back to
tell me what my test results were I
never saw that never once did I see a
doctor that's a mistake to not see
longitudinal biometric data the whole
concept of Hale is there's a lot of
population data in there that's
interesting but the whole idea is
longitudinal data we can start to see
what's happened we can think about
optimization because we can look at that
launched you know data but no one ever
looked longitudinally no one ever said
to me Doug here's where you are today
here's where you were yesterday here's
the slope of the line right you're your
glucose levels are going up your HP 1
and 1c you're going up you know you're
clearly sedentary your weights going up
and we can plot that line out because
they can do this they just said you're
fine
you know yeah we put on a little weight
eat a little less exercise a little more
but you could map that out right and my
my belief is that you know you'll have
the early movers that the suit soon as
they hear it they'll take changing
action you now see the breaking points
where when you're 5 years from now is
when there'll be a breaking point where
you'll actually feel it inside you that
it can motivate behavior but you never
show that so the whole concept is you
can see your line go do to do and your
health can potentially increase when you
make these changes as well this is yeah
so that that's that's the concept which
is so even just collecting it and
storing it so you can look at it
longitudinally I believe has value and
it's not done it's done in an EMR but
you can't get information out of the EMR
as an individual patient or if you move
healthcare systems or anything like that
and I think they say if you're over 60
you're in probably five different
healthcare systems none of which really
share information at this point in time
so the I one of the ideas of Hale is
it's this platform that is portable that
allows you to hold that information how
do you guys take EMR as well as how the
code
how the data is coded from wearables and
how its coded from all the omics sets
and how do you actually run that through
it's fairly straightforward I mean we
collect it all you know the microbiome
data we collected in in the forms of
data that it comes through it and the
wearables you know we use api's to be
able to pull that data in and look at it
we clearly define what we want to look
at so you know different wearables have
different things they look at for our
model at least originally we're very
interested in sleep we're interested in
sleeps develop a you age weigh more when
you sleep six hours a night and study
yeah so and we look at that information
beside the genes right so I have a
genetic predisposition I have a rare a
rare variation where I need less sleep
than the general population to get full
recovery there's three variations
you know only 8% of the population has
one of two actually 10% of population
has one of two variations is a 2% 8%
that predispose you to needing Leslie
for recovery 90% of the population needs
7 to 8 hours and then there's genes that
predispose you to more restless sleep
and so we look at that with with your
sleep we look at stability of it cuz
stability of when you go to bed when you
wake up how that cycle is working is is
super important and then we look at
recovery scores we look at remand deep
sleep is your body getting the
intellectual recovery it needs is it
getting the physical recovery and deep
sleep that it needs and look at that and
then you can look at clinical markers
you can look at something like C
reactive protein and look at
inflammation in the body and how is your
body responding to potential
inflammation you bring that all together
you just get a much better picture yes
of what's happening with your house you
must have lots of data scientists and
engineers that work on the team so we do
we have I mean we have it breaks up into
you know you have your classic Python
coders building the engine then you have
a set of UI UX of how you're gonna
present this information because
presenting it's very important of course
and then you have the data scientists
right and our data scientist team is led
by gentlemen I think you've interviewed
Murray canter yeah I'm a Bayesian neural
net
work expert but is how do we look at
this information so to give you an idea
you know we've looked at we've piloted
over 150 athletes and of those athletes
they all have a different microbiome but
they cluster in the four different
microbiome some of which you read the
literature and you expect there's a few
you don't you don't read or see about
and it's it it tends to cluster in the
elite endurance athletes Ironman
National Ironman triathlete people you
know competing in Kona and places like
that that have a microbial that's very
different but very very supportive yeah
I'm making turning fibre into short
chain fatty-acids protecting your colon
so during intense exercise things don't
leak through get a near blood immune
response inflammation and so they tend
to have much lower inflammation even
though they're doing a super intense
sport something we don't think about a
lot different demographics from around
the world have different environments
that they live in different foods they
need different temperatures they're in
different amounts of sunlight different
amount of exercise that is naturally
applicable in their community etc this
is yet this is this is a very
interesting that you also of course you
need the right ways of displaying the
information to the users after you're
crunching and making it relatable to
them okay so now the application in the
immediate like half hail life's
immediate application is through sports
you know right now so I didn't come to
it through sports so I in 2016 was the
very beginning looking all this I said
and it was interesting I was talking to
a woman at a conference who was a was a
filmmaker documentary filmmaker she was
doing a film on undiagnosed medical
refugees and that and the idea was that
you had these people that had
undiagnosed diseases they had been
through the medical community they had
medical records that were alike you know
thicker than books and no doctor would
see them or look for them and they could
never understand what was wrong and a
lot of it was chronic diseases and the
woman I was talking to a gentleman at
Harvard Issac kahani had worked with
Illumina and they had sequence and they
done full genome sequencing of this
population for the film and we're
racking them but there were no new
hypotheses for most of these people even
after the full genome sequencing so I
and talking to her said well have you
tried all these other technologies out
there right that you know none of them
by themselves may solve it by looking
all this information together we might
get new hypotheses and she said now it'd
be wonderful but so hard to do it was
you know it took us a year to get you
know the sequence saying I said well I
know all these groups so we basically
said let's set up the undiagnosed
disease consortium und X consortium and
let's see if we can get these companies
these research centers to to work with
Europe there was only eight people in
that population to do this work and we
did that we did all the data collection
we got the groups to do it we presented
it in August of 2016 so we got to see it
you know in real time and new hypotheses
came about and I said wow it's ready for
primetime so I came in through
undiagnosed disease as we got into a
life think about medicine you end up in
all the insurance issues and so we
started thinking say what's a population
that are influencers that are early
adopters that probably are fairly
healthy which is which is good right I
mean even from our own insurance
perspective and and now they call them
optimal population which would be a
great base if you look at these athletes
then how do people move off of that as
they age so we came to sports and
athletes and my life came 17 years later
came full athletic I never expected to
happen but I loved it which is awesome
cuz then you're even more precisely in
the right role right well yeah to do it
so that so we said why not work with
athletes are a great population and they
were wonderful so we you know we we
needed to get not only do we need to
build the platform right and see what we
could integrate we also needed to get
people on and make sure we can do it so
we piloted and you know the response
from athletes was wonderful right I mean
I remember what was your pilot so we
continued to pilot today we've gone
commercial but we continue to pilot
because the more people you have on the
platform the more valuable summations
that cross sports across age groups age
groups you know across
ethnicity x' yeah right because a lot of
this data is different depending on
ethnicity and environment so and so we
continue to pile it and do that but but
you know athletes I didn't know athletes
are doing two completely different
things in football than they're doing in
basketball or soccer hockey etc yeah
yeah it's very very different sports
very different needs everything like
that but diet is important for all of
them
recovery is important for all of them as
well so the idea of sports is you know
basically if we give you regular
performance plans derive from this data
can you use it to not only optimize
performance but reduce injury you know
make sure you're not out for a good
portion of the season right so that
recovery you're able to compete more and
everything like that and that's the idea
peak performance longer peak performance
longevity is a big part of what we do a
lot of people are interested in that
subject today just reducing the chance
of injury which is what plagues so many
athletes yeah do you want to have a long
and healthy I mean this is just this
really when you made the when you made
the the example at the beginning of what
it's like when you're 70 to be healthy
and riding the bike for long periods of
time versus you know you're just feel
like you're crippled and same thing with
athletes when you're you know 18
sometimes the the scenario is that
you're a done after like six years like
that's all you're gonna play because
that's if you can get to 40 and while
being an athlete and and having really
strong health and making sure that
you're crunching all this very valuable
data in ways that are relatable how does
Tom Brady still super ball star right
age 40 right you'll have a many how long
do they last in the league versus people
that are out I agree I sort of laughing
because cross sports to a-rod others
like LeBron James LeBron James is known
for longevity right this is the first
year he's probably struggling Derek
Jeter in New York Yankee was known for
longevity in the sport if you look at
their training programs and how they
train and you know they they tend to be
with functional doctors that don't look
at symptoms
look at root causes and an approach it
that way so I was chuckling no because
commercially you know we do one of the
areas we focus on commercially is with
elite age group athletes right and you
know it's it you win on both sides you
have the the crazy parents that want
their kids college scholarship to be
professional and they'll do anything you
know any information to get them there
then you have the other subset of
parents who are like you know my my son
or daughter is really good but they're
training a lot I want to make sure they
don't blow out their shoulders that's
been your college and lose that
opportunity to be part of that team
right so you you basically you know
you're looking at both sides of that
same same as health longevity how can I
stay this healthy how can I make sure I
don't end up with these diseases as well
this is it's so insane like you said
just the amount of data flow that we
have right now and how we're finally
making sense the most important thing to
do right now is to make sense of the
data flows and there's so many variables
that go into this too which makes it so
crazy cuz when you're when you're 18 and
when you're from a different part of the
world versus when you're 38 and you're
from a different part of the world these
are completely you know different ages
different humans different biometrics
across all these different facets here
this you know your the way that you
explain it being so comprehensive across
the different areas all the way from
sleep all the way to microbiome and it's
just to me this is the way it has to be
done and to start making sense of it and
chipping away at our ignorant with it it
is so crucial for everyone to eventually
be able to live that life curve where
they're feeling throughout the entirety
of their life I agree it's interesting
because you know clearly we come from a
system level so don't just know one
piece of information but know multiple
piece of information and I you know it
sounds beautiful when we're talking
about and tarrano interrogation and
integrated plans mean you realize the
state of the art now is you know no one
has all
these datasets right there's people that
have genes right there's there's you
know hospital systems have clinical labs
over years and years and years but no
one's really collected all of this
different type of information let alone
looked at it so we look we work with
some of the leading research groups we
do work with open medicine Institute out
of Mountain View California that came
out of Stanford group sick data at data
engineers they can really look at this
information begin to integrate it but
I'd be lying if we told you a we can
pinpoint it I think one of the beauties
of what we're doing at Hale is we're
basically setting up this platform that
researchers gonna be able to come in to
and say you know this is interesting I
want to look at someone that has these
microbes and these percentages in their
gut that have these gene variations and
are showing up these clinical labs and
they can pull that information look at
it and my hope would be they say oh my
gosh yes I think here's something that
you can use that then advances our
state-of-the-art so I mean back up a
little bit you know so what do we
actually do so for athletes we look at
46 sports related genes right so we we
tell you you know one of three
variations and in these 46 changes we
look at 72 different clinical labs
everything from inflammation to muscle
recovery to hydration markers to iron
levels to all the hormonal balances and
what impacts that we we look at the
microbiome so we're looking at nutrition
what you what you eat what are the
microbes in your gut are they
pro-inflammatory are they diverse and
what the impact may be we give all the
athletes a wearable where we can track
we can track sleep we can track sleep we
can track the different you know parts
of sleep so REM sleep deep sleep
whether it's fitful or not how many
times you wake up and the night but it
also tracks activity yeah and I'll cover
heart rate and recovery heart rate
variability is a big thing we tend to
look at and then for the athletes we put
them on a force plate we can measure
right leg left leg dominance and balance
characteristics and the feet where
they're generating force from we also
can measure power measurements and
different straight measurements on
neuromuscular coordination neuromuscular
activation so we're gathering all that
information and it basically like this
slide shows go
was into nine different attributes that
we characterize that mean a lot for
sports now if you move away from sports
energy levels recovery nutrition mental
preparedness sleep are all impactful for
myself and life as a non-athlete in
Israel as well but these are the ones we
look at for athletes to be able to
report back on on attributes that they
think about right what is my recovery
what's my endurance what's my power you
know during during an athletic season so
right now in use you both pilots and in
use so to explain it to us on quick on a
summary of where yeah so we so so we
built this platform we are now
commercializing it so where are our
primary markets on the commercial side
our elite age-group teams and programs
you know the parents are still involved
they're paying for all of this the kids
need this information it's a great time
to be back before they go to Quran like
1600 so 16 17 18 into college then we
also work with performance centers so
these aren't it's a team but you know
elite athletes will go through these
performance centers so we work there and
the other area that we weren't planning
on but it just got a lot of interest
through all the testing we're doing is
people just came up to us and said I
want this information for general health
I work with a trainer is it available so
we started working with some gyms and
and through the trainers that they can
provide to people that they train is
similar to the performance center so we
do that commercially but we want to keep
getting people on the platform so we
pilot so we've piloted some of the
premier dancers at New York City Ballet
at Paul Taylor Dance Company we're about
to do Alvin Ailey a big you know
traditional african-american dance
troupe fantastic group out of New York
City a set of major league and minor
league baseball players all coming
through Performance Center in Atlanta
we've done triathletes and will continue
to pilot there's another nice part we do
you know again the problem with a lot of
health care and medicine is is yes the
people that can afford
get the benefit what about everybody
else inside I've always been a big
believer and it's big in the world now
of doing something socially as well
right so I grew up I first started my
diving career in a YMCA when you think
of YMCAs and YWCA s now you don't think
of elite you think of them as sort of
you know linchpins of communities Yeah
right and a lot of times it's
economically disadvantaged people that
are still taking advantage of them other
people might come through but then go
off to do elite select program so we're
starting a program where for every 10
people you know athletes etc we test we
test somebody through YMCA there's still
that sports connection and the YMCA YWCA
but you get a different population that
otherwise might not have this this
ability to do this testing you know ever
or until they were we're an elite level
athlete that's great that's actually
gonna take you even further because
there's yeah there's a lot of
Millennials in Gen Z that are really
following on to the mission statements
of businesses among the social impact
that they're gonna have and whatnot so
the more that you can also work with the
the the different clients that you have
on helping them understand the
principles of your mission so that they
can also potentially help along with the
social impact that's actually really big
and I think it'll take you definitely
together it's important it's important
in tech because again tech you know you
see this pulling a partisan back to the
original questions pulling a part of
society it's becoming less egalitarian
right and and there's a lot of forces
driving that and and this is one in
medicine in healthcare right could be
one so I just it's it's a nice match to
be able to to do that and it's also well
within the confines of medicine when
concierge yes--and started coming about
a lot of those concierge clinics did you
know a certain percentage of their
business with people that couldn't
afford to pay for it because it matched
sort of the you know that you know
what's the Hippocratic oath or something
right but providing health care to
everyone so there's there's a whole
history of doing that in health care as
well
where is this going in your vision let's
say in the next you know a couple of
decades as more as this opens up more
and more to all humans around the plant
and we're getting a constant stream of
these insights about our biometric
States where do you see this kind of
going yeah so I think I mean we're
starting we're starting with sports we
did that because influenced earlier
adopters I mean a lot of commercial
reasons as well as as a fundamental one
which is that's an optimal population so
it'd be great to have this type of data
of population data so you know how do I
compare to 5,000 other college
volleyball players yeah minor league or
major league baseball players or NFL
football players what are the ones at
the peak yeah of their performance doing
what do they look like can I can i if I
want to get there what will it take what
do I need to do by the way that's
fantastic behavioral motivation the
thing that it lasts in medicine right
now is the doctor says eat less and
exercise more and then goes you didn't
do what I told you to do like there's no
motivation there and there's a lot of
companies now working on behavioral
change but that's the best one is I I
want to get there what does LeBron James
look like but more importantly
longitudinally looking at you you know
what what what are you do when you're at
your best performance what is aligning
in your body versus when you're feeling
sluggish and things aren't going as well
and and trying to get yourself into that
that top level position but athletes are
this optimal population my belief still
was the original sort of foundation from
this when we created Hale life which was
you know optimizing health through
performance medicine right reimagining
primary care medicine I believe there's
an incredible opportunity out there to
basically take primary care medicine or
the doctors hate it
insurance eight to 12 minutes the
doctors don't get to know their their
patients they don't get to solve the
problems of their patients the patient's
hate it because they get 9 minutes in
and they start telling the doctor all of
their real symptoms things happening the
doctor has to leave doctors are working
harder than they ever had for for less
reimbursement than they have ever had
and we're fighting chronic disease the
age of infectious disease we've solved
that chronic disease two thirds of the
healthcare budget
over two trillion dollars you don't
solve by giving someone a pill and
sending them home and solve it through
behavioral changes and so you know to me
Laura Mary Kerr has this opportunity to
go
you got you got urgent scares that'll go
telemedicine you need stitches you got
strep throat yeah go solve it you got
specialists it'll always do what
specialist does but primary care
physicians why can't we be health
coaches and and I have an in bigger
vision which is you know we have these
gyms we all go to the gym right we go to
the gym we go to massage therapists we
go to chiropractors or anything like
that and all of that is in some respects
I'll find the health care system or at
least fringing to the health care system
why don't we actually have if I was a
primary care doctor I'm gonna own a gym
and every day people are gonna come
three times a week four times a week two
times a week to that gym I'm gonna see
them what's happening how are you
feeling I'm gonna test them now I'm
gonna say five minutes are there one day
I'm gonna test them in another day when
they come back say hey spend twenty
minutes with me it's just like your
financial advisors sure let me show you
your your reports let's talk about this
what do you want to do what do you want
to focus on this year and now ago an
integrated health center that has all
these components have words to it and
make it its prescriptive its proactive
now you're collaborating with your
physician and if it was running a hell
because he gets to see you in the gym
are you working out what you give your
own changes that you're on you about you
and I think there's a great opportunity
to change it and that's what you need to
solve chronic disease and it's easy
because you can do it with data and you
can do it collaboratively and you don't
need the doctor running a gym there's a
billion different ways to do it but
basically I think you can move it into
that sphere and now you know primary
care doctor you know has meaning again
right and I love you dude I love your
vision Doug your vision is really strong
it's really strong this is why you've
you know been spending the last the over
13 years now specifically on this I
always joke you go I you know I went the
opposite route right I went into venture
capital venture capital because it
became institutionalized the guys that
are sitting on your board meeting and
doing all talking Muslim have never run
a business in their life right have no
idea they're probably answering to
somebody else because everybody's
answering to somebody else and do that
and that's not what venture capital was
in its prime in its glory and I finally
looked at myself I said well I mean I
run a company but I run an investment
company why don't I do this so at age
you know 48 said I'm gonna become the 25
year old hunter preneur and see if I can
really build a company you have exciting
sights from your life trajectory
especially in sport across all the
sciences that really put you in the
right position here to be able to do
this and again I just I really like your
vision a lot I think there's gonna be a
huge change in what's happening with all
of this data of making sense of all the
data
I loved your vision of an actual into
like a health center that actually has
all these components built into it and
you're actually monitoring humans
biometrics and making sure they're uh
this is this is a totally futuristic
vision I'm excited to see it come to
fruition I have two quick questions for
you on the way out don't we like asking
our guests first of all it's simulation
are we in a simulation yeah that's a
question you always ask yourself it's
the it's the matrix but you know
wherever they think they got out of it
or every time you're out of it are you
just in another simulation I love that
in the Matrix movie I wish they had
gotten into that no I mean life is real
and and and all of the emotions and the
passions of life are are truly real and
I think that's the wonderful part of
life and I think when you step out of
the simulation and you you can
experience real life and you can
experience it in real time I mean you
know this I mean you know the fact that
you're working really hard and doing all
that but you realize what you're doing
at the same moment I mean that to me is
reality so so I'm a believer in in
reality if I sometimes wonder if just
ripping up the civilians and the last
question is what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world what do I
think is the most beautiful thing in the
ideal world man I think I think I don't
think it's a single thing I think it's
you know to envisioning something an
idea right maybe it's even before that
aspiration to idea to realization right
I think that that
that flow yeah that process aspiration
idea realization is I mean it's it's
life it's wonderful when it happens when
you can make it happen it's also and
when you can realize it's actually
happening is is the best thing in the
world I mean some of it athletes the
athletes that sort of you know you're in
the Olympics I'm the best competition in
their life and they're going on to do
something no one has ever done right
aspiration idea I can be an Olympian to
the execution I'm a gold medalist I've
done something that so few people have
done and understand it be part of it
live it while you're experiencing it
that to me is uh that's awesome I mean
that's the greatest thing in life oh I
love it there's everything that we see
around us in civilization
was this aspiration and then this idea
and this realization of it into the
world that we get the privilege of being
able to use on these daily bases and
even when you fly when you do all these
things when you have these great medical
treatments that prolong your life so
long like it's just so incredible what
human creativity has and I've been able
to bring us to an accomplished don't
really want to follow up soon and you
know we have so much more to unpack
about all of the nuance about the
technology and about the biometric
states of our bodies and having a long
state of prosperity with our health and
I'm really excited to see where the the
engines and the insights are going with
this so thank you no thank you great
visionary this is all thank you very
much you you know I got this has been
such a pleasure doc thank you so much
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you guys tuning in we'd love
to hear from your thoughts in the
comments below let us know what you're
thinking about what's happening in the
state of transitioning to a more
prosperous technology with our
healthcare also thank you to Ron Vargas
for producing and directing we would
love for you to subscribe join the
community join the conversations that we
have going on
also keep supporting artists and
entrepreneurs keep supporting the
visionaries that you want to see their
ideas come to reality remember to check
out Hale life's links below and much
love
building the future we'll see you guys
soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
you